لا لا نريد مواجهه الدب الروسي يكفينا
حوادث هكذا خضع الكيان الاسرائيلي
لتهديدات بوتين
[موسيقى]
تتعهد بعدم استهداف الاراضي الروسيه فما
الذي يجري دومباس تعود للمائده الروسيه
وانسحابات تدريجيه للجيش الاوكراني من
باخموت وبوتين يعد بعدم المساسي بزلنسكي
بينما تفضح موسكو مسرحيه الامريكان
الهزليه للعراق بكين لواشنطن نحتفظ بحق
الرد بكافه الوسائل وحرب اخرى تندلع بين
الصينيين والامريكيين واصحاب العيون
الضيقه يصنعون روبوتا خارقا للعاده لا
يمكن حبسه تركيا تطبخ خططها في سوريا على
نار هادئه فيما مصر تكتشف كنزا بمليارات
الدولارات والجزائر تظهر معنا الانسانيه
روسيا تطبخ حربا كبرى
التهديدات الروسيه تتطاير يمنه ويسرى لكن
لا يلتقطها الجميع لتكون
من يتجنب تحضير الدب الروسي في اعلان وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني ان بلاده لن تستهدف
الاراضي الروسيه بالاسلحه الغربيه بعيده
المدى وبرغم ان استخباراتك اذ كانت قد
اعلنت ان موسكو صارت هدفا مشروعا لكن
الغرب لا يغامر بخطوه كهذه ليؤكد المستشار
الالماني عن وجود اتفاق مع زلنسكي يقضي
بعدم استخدام الاسلحه الغربيه المرسله
لاوكرانيا من اجل استهداف الاراضي الروسيه
من يتجنبون مواجهه الروس همكثر لكن هذه
المره يقولها رئيس وزراء الكيان
الاسرائيلي بان اسرائيل لا تريد مواجهه مع
روسيا ووقوعها حوادث بين الطائرات
العسكريه لكلا البلدين في السوريه وذلك
بحسب قناه ال سي اي الفرنسيه مضيفا انه تم
التوصل لحل وسط مع الرئيس الروسي بوتين
بحيث لا يتم انتهاك العلاقات مع موسكو
هناك تمد كييف نظرها نحو المملكه
البريطانيه ليقول الرئيس الاوكراني
انه بحث كيفيه زياده التوسع في قدرات
الجيش الاوكراني خلال اتصال هاتفيا مع
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
لكن ماذا ناقشتم خلال الاتصال ايضا
يزالنسكي دعونا نعود قليلا الى الحرب
الاوكرانيه يا اصدقاء حيث لا جديد غير
التقدمات الروسيه المتواصله وقال قائد
مجموعه باجنر الروسيه الملقب بطباخ بوتين
ان قتالا عنيفا مستمرا للاجزاء الشماليه
لمدينه بخموت الاوكرانيه التي كانت محط
اهتمام القوات الروسيه منذ اسابيع مضيفا
انهم يقات من شارع لشارع ومنزل لمنزل ضد
القوات الاوكرانيه التي لم تنسحب من مدينه
بخموت وبينما تكمل القوات الروسيه طوقها
بشكل كامل على بخموت قالت وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه ان روسيا احرزت تقدمًا في
تطبيق دومباس لتعلن وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه عن مقتل وجرح 140 عنصر من
مجموعه
في معركه بخموت لياتي الخبر اليقين من
مجله ان قوات كييف تنسحب تدريجيا من بخموت
وتخلي بعض المناطق هناك بسبب نقص الذخيره
والجنود ينفض مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني
الغبار عن جسده ويقول ان التهديدات
الروسيه الاخيره بشن ضربات انتقاميه ضد
بلاده هي محاوله لتركيع الاوكرانيين مشيرا
الى ان بلاده ستستعد كل اراضيها باي وسيله
ومن بين ركام الاخبار
ظهر رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي السابق ليصرح
انه اخذ وعدا من الرئيس الروسي بوتين بعدم
قتل نظيره الاوكراني
لنعد الى التعليقات الروسيه ولكن ليست
زخروا فهذه المره بل نائب وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه متحدثا عن غزو العراق الجائر حيث
قال لقد اصبحت صوره كولين باول وهو يظهر
انبوب اختبار به مسحوق يزعم انه الجمره
الخبيثه منذ فتره طويله تجسيدا للنفاق
وثقه النخبه الامريكيه الحاكمه بافلاتها
من العقاب في تلك المسرحيه المخزيه على
ارض بلاد الرافدين ومن معارك التصريحات
الى حرب الايتاوات والضرائب حيث يهدد
الاوروبيون باتخاذ اجراءات ضد بريطانيا في
حال القى رئيس وزراء
[موسيقى]
وقال مسؤول امريكي ان الحطام موجود على
عمق 47 قدما ما يسهل عمليه جمعه بحسب شبكه
سي ان
تبني جيشا اخر غير المناطيل هنا روبوت
صيني يتحول من الحاله الصلبه الى الحاله
السائله ويتمكن من تحرير نفسه من خلف
القضبان بسهوله درب العلماء الصينيون
الروبوت على الحركه ونقل الحموله حيث يقوم
هذا الروبوت وهو في الحاله الصلبه بنقل
حموله اكبر من وزنه ب 30 مره وبمواجهه تلك
الجيوش الصينيه يتجه الامريكان لنشر
صواريخ متوسطه المدى باليابان في اطار خطه
لتعزيز الدفاعات في مواجهه الصين ببحريه
الشرقي والجنوبي وفق صحيفه سانك اليابانيه
وتضيف الصحيفه ان ارسال العتاب بالقوات
الامريكيه في اليابان قد اسلحه بعيده
المدى اسرع من الصوت والصواريخ توماهوك
انقره تتقرب من دمشق مع اقتراب المصالحه
بين النظام السوري وتركيا ماذا تريد انقره
من دمشق وما الذي يريده بشار الاسد من
اردوغان ليطرق وردان مجددا ابوابا النظام
السوري لتحقيق تقارب معه تحت رعايه روسيه
بالاساس قد يحصل هذا لاول مره منذ اندلاع
الحرب في سوريا ما قد يغير خارطه الصراع
بشكل كبير هنا قد تكون الولايات المتحده
الخاسر الاكبر بين القوه الدوليه وتعد
تركيا طرفا اساسيا في الصراع في سوريا
دمشق تريد انسحابا جزئيا او كليا بالقوات
التركيه من اراضيها بينما تحاول انقره
توفير مناخ امن لبدء عوده اللاجئين
السوريين الى بلادهم والذين يقدر
بثلاثه ملايين ونصف المليون لاجئ فضلا عن
تعاون سوريا مع تركيا للتعامل مع الجماعات
الكرديه يرغب اردوغان بهذه الاليات قبل
خوض الانتخابات القادمه اما روسيا سيكسبها
استقرار سوريا حليفا دائما في السلم
والحرب كما ان مصالحه انقره ودمشق قد تعني
تخلي الامريكان عن النفط السوري وهو ما
تحسب له واشنطن الف حساب
الاحداث والتطورات
الجزائر يصادق على مشروع قانون يجرم
الاتجار بالبشر بعقوبه قد تصل للمؤبد
بينما تستمر جهود الحكومه الجزائريه
لمضاعفه زراعه القمح بهدف الوصول للاكتفاء
الذاتي وتجنب اثار ازمه الغذاء العالميه
النرويج تمنع احراق نسخه من المصحف بعد
استدعاء سفيرها في تركيا منجم ايقات في
الصحراء مصر الشرقيه هو احدث المناجم التي
اكتشفت مؤخرا في تلك المنطقه وهو كنز جديد
قد يوفر مليارات الدولارات للمصريين الاف
الاسرائيليين في شوارع تل ابيب ضد حكومه
نتنياهو في اطار احتجاجات تخرج اسبوعيا
وطيار اسرائيلي يهدد علنا باغتيال رئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو قال استمر في تنفيذ خطه
لاصلاح القضاء تصفها المعارضه بالانقلاب
رساله موسكو تصل والدول تعلن تجنب مواجهه
الروس بينما يتجه نظر واشنطن لمواجهه
الصين مع تجميع الخلفاء لكن بكين تعد لهم
الجيوش بين مناطيد وروبوتات وغيرها الكثير
فمن يقوى على مواجهه اصحاب العيون الضيقه
بعد هذا كله
[موسيقى]